You're making these communication
mistakes right now that you can't see.
Yes, you. And it's costing you your
career. I've made those mistakes for the
last 10 years before anyone even told
me. You see, I was building my career
and as a keynote speaker, I thought I
was bloody [music] brilliant. But within
many of my key interactions in
high-stakes meetings, my communication
skills, well, they let me down, which
caused me to be overlooked for the
bigger opportunities that existed. My
name's Vin, I'm a communication skills
expert and after training some of the
biggest companies in the world like
Zoom, Microsoft, and teaching millions
of people to improve the way they speak,
I keep seeing these five same mistakes
show up again and again. By the end,
you'll know how to spot them and the
exact behaviors to replace them with.
Mistake number one, you forget the
question you're being asked. This
happens to all of us and I know it's
happened to you, too, where someone on
your team asks you a simple question
about a project like Vin, are we still
on track for project Neo this Friday?
Oh, um yeah, well, yeah, yeah, um
project Neo. So, so, we we we kicked off
a bit later than than planned because we
decided we needed a bit more time on the
wireframes and then the dev found a
couple of issues and there was
integration problems next week to make
sure things are great.
Of course. It was so funny, you had to
be there. Oh, wait. What Wait, what was
I asking you? No, no, sorry, sorry.
Wait, um I think were you asking me
something? What was the question again?
Oh, man. Did you notice that? Why does
this happen to you? Why does it happen
to me? Why does it happen to all of us?
Well, there's a few things that's
happening in your subconscious mind.
When you first get asked a question
about your project, you might be too
focused on trying to prove that you're
on top of everything, so you share all
the details as evidence. You're anxious
about leaving something important out,
so you overcorrect and you include every
single detail. You haven't actually
thought in your own head what the actual
answer is, so you talk your way towards
the point instead of just starting with
the point. When you do this, you
actually think you're adding value. You
think, "Well, they asked me about the
project, so I should tell them about the
project." But most of the time, they're
just seeking a high-level status check,
not inviting you to dump all the
context. And the unfortunate thing is
when this happens too often in front of
your leaders and your managers, they
don't see you as brilliant and thorough.
They see you [music] as unclear and hard
to follow, which is why the next time a
question gets thrown your way, here's a
three-part communication framework I
want you to use. It's called ACQ. The A
stands for answer,
the C stands for context,
and the Q stands for question. Answer
their question with just one clear
sentence and add a little bit of context
only if you need to. And then after
that, ask them a clarifying question
like, "Do you want more detail?" So then
they can pull more from you if they
actually need it. And here is what that
looks like. Hey Vin, are we still on for
project Neo this Friday? Yes, we are
still on track for Friday. We started a
bit late because design needed a little
more time, but the plan is aligned with
next week's QA window. [music]
Did you need any more detail? No, that's
all I need to know.
Awesome.
Now, wasn't that way better? By using a
communication framework like ACQ when
answering questions, especially in a
work context, it ensures you actually do
answer the question and you don't lose
yourself in a rambling mess. That's
invisible mistake number one. But
invisible mistake number two is even
sneakier because when you do it, you
think you're coming across as
thoughtful, but people actually perceive
it as [music] confusing. And mistake
number two is when you externalize your
thought process. This is when you think
out loud when the situation calls for a
formed thought. I was in a meeting last
week with a highly credible individual.
I had zero doubts about their knowledge
and expertise. But when I asked them a
simple question, the way they answered
it suddenly made me question everything.
Instead of pausing, finding a clear
answer, and then responding, he just
spoke his thinking process out loud, led
me down different paths, and left me
more confused than I was when I started.
It sounded something like this. So Vin,
what do you think our next step should
be? Ah, I think it should be option A.
Wait, maybe not because if we do go with
option A, then we'd have to actually
Hold on. What if we went with option B?
What if we did that instead? No way,
that doesn't make sense. We should
circle back to option D.
What do you think of that? Actually, you
know what? Stuff it, okay? Stuff it.
We're going to go with option G, which
stands for what? Elephant.
I used to do this all the time. I share
this with you for the simple reason that
many of us, we know internally that we
are smart, we are knowledgeable, and
we're capable. But the moment we open
our mouths as we speak, our
communication skills let us down. It
causes people to undermine us and
overlook us. And hey, by watching this
video, [music] by applying the
frameworks that I teach you, the ones
you're learning right now, you're not
just speaking better, you're actively
reshaping the way people perceive you.
Because when you improve your
communication skills, you amplify the
best parts of you to those around you.
Now, how do you avoid externalizing your
thought process? I've already given you
the answer in mistake number one by
using communication frameworks.
Communication frameworks are your best
friend, especially when you need to
answer questions on the spot or you're
put in high-pressure situations. When
you're put on the spot, generally what
happens is you get nervous, which causes
your mind to go blank, and then you lose
your train of thought, which causes you
to ramble and externalize your thinking.
Frameworks allow you to lean on
structures when your mind is in chaos.
And I've actually recorded a free
training where I've distilled three of
the most powerful communication
frameworks I use every single day in
high-stakes meetings or in everyday
conversations, so that I stop rambling,
I speak in a way that's more clear, in a
way that's more concise, in a way that's
more coherent. Click the link below or
scan the QR code on screen if you want
to access that free training. Speaking
with frameworks is the difference
between sounding scattered and being the
person people listen to, trust, and
promote. So make sure you check it out.
So what's the best framework to avoid
speaking your thinking process out loud?
I actually posted a video recently
sharing the exact process I'd used to
stop rambling, so go watch that if you
want the process in detail. But I'll
quickly summarize it here for you, too.
Don't answer immediately. Pause.
>> [snorts]
>> Take a deep breath and move into the
thinker pose, which is this.
This gives you time to actually think
about the answer. And when you do this,
you might think, "Oh, Vin, it's so weird
to pause like that." But trust me, it
makes you come across more thoughtful
and it creates more anticipation for
what you're about to say next.
Once you've thought of the answer in
your head, then go ahead and use ACQ,
the framework we learned earlier. Again,
it's answer, context, question. I'll
show you what that looks like in action,
[music] all of it. So Vin, what do you
think our next step should be?
>> [music]
>> Look, I recommend we go with option B
because if we go with option A, we're
going to hit scaling issues in quarter
three. How's [music] that sound to you?
>> [laughter]
>> See that? In the first version, I
verbalized the entire decision tree. In
the second version, I delivered the
decision. That's not to say you
shouldn't ever verbalize your thoughts
out loud. There are times for this where
it's useful, like when you're
brainstorming or you're collaborating
with other people where this is
necessary. But when someone needs a
decision, a position, verbalizing your
thoughts in those particular moments, it
costs you credibility. You're showing
them a rough draft when what they want
is actually the final version. And look,
I get it. A lot of us were trained to
show our work, especially if you've got
a technical role like being an engineer.
You were rewarded for transparency, for
showing the exact steps that you took.
That's great for problem-solving. But
when it comes to communicating,
especially in high-stakes situations, it
can come across overwhelming and
confusing. All right, let's get into
mistake number three. You're defaulting
to agreement without a position. It took
me years before I could recognize this
mistake within my own communication.
It's when you remain neutral in every
decision or question that comes your
way. Imagine someone on your team asks
the following.
What do you guys want to eat for lunch?
Yeah, look, I don't really mind where we
go.
Okay.
Dan? I'm easy. Whatever the team wants.
Vin?
Oh, yeah. Well, look, I'm just going to
be vague like everybody else because I
don't want to bear the weight of the
decision of where we have lunch because
if I pick a place and then nobody likes
it and then you'll blame me. So, I don't
know. Whatever you guys want to eat. I'm
cool with that. Whatever.
Oh, man.
Can you see the problem? How annoying is
that? Not only is it frustrating when
your friends can't make a decision on
where to go to eat, you end up not
bloody going anywhere. But in a work
context, it gives off the impression
that you just go along with other
people's decisions, that you don't have
an opinion yourself, and you're scared
of making the wrong move. But by not
actually taking a position, it makes you
forgettable. And look, this one's
relatable to so many of us because
growing up, a lot of us were taught that
being agreeable is the right thing. It
helps us avoid conflict. Especially
early in your career, you don't want to
seem difficult, you don't want to seem
overly opinionated, so you stay neutral.
But being neutral doesn't make you
easier to work with. And it's invisible
to you because you think you're being
flexible, but to others, it signals a
lack of decisiveness. And if you do this
too often, you slowly exclude yourself
from key decisions. Maybe you do have an
opinion. Maybe you're just not sure yet.
So, you default to being neutral because
you think it's safer. And again, maybe
you're scared if you're too direct, it
makes you difficult to work with. But
what happens as a result?
>> [music]
>> People stop asking you for your opinion.
In other words, you're making yourself
irrelevant. So, how do you avoid this?
Here's exactly what you do. When someone
asks you a question, actually take a
moment to pause and think of your
position, and then follow the PRO
framework. The P stands for position,
which means state your position, and
then the R stands for reason,
which essentially means give a reason
for the position that you have. And then
the O stands for open, which essentially
is you opening it up for questions. And
remember, if you want to learn the three
most powerful communication frameworks
that I use on a daily basis, remember to
check out my free training in the
description below.
So, for example, if you're in a team
meeting and your manager says the
following, "We have two options. We can
either post one video a week on YouTube
or two videos." What do you say? My
position is we should be posting two
videos a week. We've seen a 200%
increase in subscribers over the last
month, and we need to double down on
this while the channel has momentum. If
we did move to two videos a week, what's
the one thing you'd want new viewers to
do when they land on one of our videos?
Peter, the answer is simple. They should
like the video they're watching and hit
subscribe because we're not going to
move on from this skit until
they do.
I love how creative we can be with
getting you to subscribe. I mean, did
you do it? No, but seriously, if you
want to support us, that teeny weeny
action goes a long way. All right, back
to the point. Did you see how powerful
that example was in the skit? Did it
come across difficult? Absolutely not.
So, remember to use the PRO framework
more often when you're asked about your
input on something because people who
actually stand for something are the
ones who influence decisions. [music]
Okay, this next mistake is something I
can guarantee 99% of people [music] do.
Mistake number four is not leading the
energy. When you're in a room with a
group of people, you let the room decide
how you show up. If they're quiet,
you're quiet. If they're energetic,
you're energetic. And there's nothing
particularly wrong with that because
this is how you build rapport with
people fast, by meeting people where
they are and matching their energy. What
I am talking about is understanding that
you have the power to shift the energy
in the room and setting the tone for the
people to match you instead of just you
matching others. This is one of the
traits of great leaders. They don't just
copy the energy in the room, they set
the tone. For me, when I'm talking to my
team every single day, there are moments
that require high levels of passion.
Then there are moments that require deep
levels of focus. As we move from light
to funny topics to more serious and
thoughtful ones, as a leader, I
deliberately shift the way I show up.
I'm guiding the energy of the people
around me. And this is what makes you
magnetic and charismatic as a
communicator. You don't just contribute
a thought, you shift people's energy.
So, practically, how do you do this? How
do you not only match people's energy,
but actually set the tone of the room so
that others follow your lead? Well, step
number one, you have to learn to read
the room. Understand how people are
currently showing up with their level of
energy.
Think about how people are using their
voice. Are they loud? Are they quiet?
Are they talking fast or slow? Is the
topic playful or is it serious and
heavy?
Once you get a good read of the room,
step two is to match and mirror them. If
they're calm and thoughtful, don't
engage them with a loud volume. Meet
them with calmness.
Again,
>> [music]
>> why is this important? Because it
creates harmony and makes people feel
like you get them. And only once you
feel you're in rapport, then you move to
step three, which is to shift your voice
slowly to guide them to the energy level
you want it to be at.
If you're calm and thoughtful and you
want to shift the energy to something
more light and playful, you add a bit
more volume, a bit more warmth and
melody into your voice. You're still
with them. You're just inviting them to
a different level. In a leadership
context, your job is to meet people
where they are and then take them to
where the conversation needs [music] to
go. And yes, this is hard. You don't
need to be a motivational speaker on
standby 24/7, but the people who grow
the fastest and create the most impact,
they aren't afraid to set the tone of
the room and not just conform. Here's
the last one. This is the one that kept
me stuck the longest. Mistake number
five, not playing your instrument to its
fullest potential. Imagine a friend
gifted you a guitar, but he never
actually taught you how to play it. That
guitar will sit on the shelf, collect
dust, and become wasted potential. Most
of you don't realize this, but your
voice is also an instrument. And just
like how my friend gave me this guitar
without teaching me how to play it, no
one actually gave you the instruction
manual on how to use your voice.
When was the last time someone sat you
down and taught you how to play with
your instrument, your voice? It took me
over 10 years to master my communication
skills, and I can tell you right now,
it's the one skill that has transformed
my life. And I don't say that lightly.
I've been lucky enough to help millions
of people unlock their voice and play
their instruments better. And when they
do, they unlock their potentials in
their careers. They get promoted. They
get recognized and finally get seen for
the value that they bring, not just the
work they do in the background. So, what
does playing your instrument actually
look like? Well, most of us only play
the same five keys on the piano
regardless of what we're talking about.
They use the same melody. They use the
same rate of speech, and they use the
same volume kind of like I'm doing right
now. The goal is to learn how to play
all 88 keys of your piano
or guitar, however many keys there are
on that instrument over there. The goal
is to learn how to be dynamic as a
communicator. And what's a practical way
to do this? Learning how to control a
few simple dials, your rate of speech,
your volume, your melody. When you speed
up, it makes you sound more passionate.
When you slow down, it adds weight to
your words and it highlights what you're
saying. When you speak loud, you're
showing confidence and vitality. And
when you speak quietly, you're forcing
[music] people to lean in. And when you
add a little bit more melody to your
voice, not only does it make you more
dynamic, it makes you more engaging and
memorable. The greatest communicators
know how to control these dials when
they're communicating, and they mix it
up to keep you engaged. Sometimes they
speed up. Sometimes they lower their
voice. Sometimes they use lots of
melody. This is what makes you more
dynamic and also makes you easier to
listen to. These are the five mistakes
that most people make when they speak,
and now you can't unsee it. Sorry.
Replace these mistakes with the new
behaviors I've shared with you in this
video, and you've unlocked a whole new
version of you that no longer is
overlooked and ignored, but rather is
respected and listened to.
Don't be so attached to who you are in
the present [music] that you don't give
the future version of you a chance. Make
sure you check out the link in the
description for my free training to dive
deeper into communication frameworks.
I'll see you in the next video.